Next question today, David, as far as the
2020 Democratic primary campaign goes, are
Democrats better off, going hard, left or
appealing to moderates for the purpose of
ultimately defeating Trump in 2020?
Excellent question.
And the answer to me is so clear that I don't
want to equivocate in any way appealing to
moderates has never been a good strategy and
it has never demonstrably worked at the national
level.
Now we can separate this out from particular
districts or even state Senate seats, a Senate
seats, which are the voting public isn't entire
state is what I'm trying to say.
It's the wrong approach to even be thinking
in these terms though, and that's what really
scares me.
Democrats shouldn't calculate should we go
hard left or should we deliberately go to
the middle in order to defeat Donald Trump
in 2020 or for for whatever particular reason,
Democrats and people who are voting in democratic
primaries and people who are voting in general
should vote for who they want to vote for
on the basis of how those individuals lineup
with their beliefs.
And it's perfectly reason to think about how
those individuals would fare in a national
campaign who can avoid mistakes, who can handle
gaffes, who can deal with attack opposition
research.
Those are the questions that need to be asked,
not let's calculate where on the political
spectrum.
We want to pick someone with the idea of bringing
in as many moderates and center rightists
as possible, who might be disaffected by Donald
Trump or whoever is the republican that we
are running against.
Pick the person that you believe is best suited
for a national campaign and whose politics
aligned with yours.
Make that person the nominee and then they
can run against Trump.
And the question is not to calculate who's
going to do better against Trump based on
are they center or center left or far further
left the, the question is, uh, who is it that
actually represents the views of Americans
and what we know from every single poll that
fairly asks, uh, Americans about their political
positions.
We know that Americans are weld to the left
of the elected officials that are representing
us.
When you fairly go to people and say, do you
think that the government has a basic duty
to provide a, a sort of starter, at least
a starter level of care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay?
Overwhelmingly two thirds to 80% of Americans
depending on, depending on the poll, say yeah,
I think that's something that should happen.
Now when you politicize it in the way that
it gets politicized, do you want the government
taking over healthcare and a uh, a socialist
and manner?
Of course people start to say, oh no, I don't
want that.
But on the issues when asked fairly income
inequality, health care, net neutrality, whatever,
um, the country has moved to the left and
our politicians have not.
So the question is not let's calculate left
center, Middle Center, left or whatever.
Let's go through the primary process supporting
the people whose views reflect our views.
Let's see who avoid mistakes and who can deal
with the gaffs and the stumbles and people
will start to emerge as leaders and we will
see whether they are going to be able to handle
the attacks that no doubt they will be presented
with if they are the Democratic nominee.
So the calculation that we need to make is
not one of what will moderates and disaffected
Republicans like.
Now, let's put aside for a second that I believe
this is the wrong question altogether.
The idea of running to the center has never
worked.
Okay?
There's this idea that if we as Democrats,
progressives left this, whatever, pick someone
that is closer to the center, we will pick
up centrists and we'll win because someone
will run numbers and say, you know, if we
get just a three additional percentage points
of the independent vote, uh, Republicans can't
win or whatever at the national level, this
just haven't worked.
Okay.
I would argue that save for Conservative districts,
Democrats running to the center is a disastrous
strategy.
There are house elect elections, okay.
Where we make the calculation and we say,
okay, what kind of Democrat can win in Virginia?
Uh, that's a different type of Democrat and
the Democrat that can win in coastal California
or in Massachusetts for example.
Uh, but the primary process already sorts
that out nationally.
This ultimately comes down to personality,
communicating ideas.
Well, staving off attacks from the other side
and avoiding scandal.
So we might as well just put somebody in whose
politics match those of the leftist voters
that are making the decision here and of Americans
more broadly.
And those have moved to the left, as I mentioned,
on just about every issue, taxing the rich
to pay for things.
I mentioned healthcare already, seriously
dealing with climate change, campaign finance,
staying out of places that aren't our business
around the world.
Pick the person that appeals to you on policy
and likability, which we know for the Democratic
primary voters is someone that is further
left of center than many of the people that
we often hear suggested as we've got to run
to the middle to bring people from the other
side over.
It hasn't worked.
It's not a defensible strategy.
Let's stop pretending that it is.